god particle front lighting helps your
audience to see you better thanks you
now for your awesome tips yeah but we
got 30 broken Alex 227 in busy whoo oh
[ __ ] jockey clothes that I was going to
distract me yeah John thank you lost
five ground geek too Booya Shaka I don't
know what youtubers say that makes them
cool yo where's like the questions and
[ __ ] yeah yeah sure yeah you buy the
next steps take turns buying beer
three lage Louise he says hi to greg and
i say hi to you lewis sup louis to
Matthew Cobb 2016 oh this is way better
when you could straighten below much
it's so much easier I can't lay our
YouTube do this easily I mean it says
it's supposed to connect them to the you
now I mean to you too but I don't see it
on youtube yeah it is you now what's
cookin more like you later when we
download this and put it up on YouTube
yeah to Matthew cubby decided to see you
I'm excited to see you too ah he also
spells spider-man spooger months you
darlin Luther man looks awesome that's
the the Nordic version this
congratulations for you two are the only
two people in on this chat right now
well it says we got seven viewers but I
only see two people talking ah five
gravity to Disney is ruling the world
right now this is so true Dizzy's yeah
disney disney own Star Wars Marvel Pixar
an occasional animated movie that his
not Pixar yeah Disneyland they're
thinking to buy netflix i almost feel
like disney grab a pixar doin hey we're
tired of being over shined by you so
you're gonna have to start making some
not as good movies we're gonna make some
incredible movies and you're gonna help
us this is very true three patrick you
one hello Patrick e holmes toe do Mackay
Kobe's just stuck on spooderman spew
Thurman tobey maguire is the best slider
man I love to I feel like Tobey
Maguire's like something Michael Keaton
of spider-man ya know Michael Keaton's
in the new spider-man you know what I
mean I'm Michael Keaton's the Batman
yeah
cuz you know like Tobey Maguire was a
lovable Peter Parker and I know people
are like oh you know he's not as much
like the spider-man of the comics but he
is the one that at least so far that
everyone likes yes is Andrew Garfield
like people are whoa ashwin or amun-ra n
do you guys watch anime oh do we are
anime enthusiasts just every day every
day and am anim all day all day every
day all day anime whatever day no we
don't really watch that much anime yeah
you gotta calm down about that trailer
man your your way to I oh dude [ __ ]
mad you know between items way too much
about is way too much about the
spider-man trailer right now so um hmm I
wish there was someone here to show us
how this works we don't really know how
you now works why are you now like
tutorial that's streaming live on you I
mean there's supposed to be a guy who's
supposed to like answer questions for us
and [ __ ] well where is it bring him to
me I want to see I don't know where he
wants you will do this for me Huntsman
all right we're gonna wait till there's
about 20 to 30 people in here and then
what we'll do is we'll talk about some
movie news real quintile about 5 20 25
30 somewhere in between there we're
planning on stopping 10 kill a fuzzy or
spider-man homecoming reaction got
blocked what I'm kidding man I've
encountered that with many videos and
sometimes you win sometimes you don't
sometimes people have theirs up
sometimes you don't just the way it is
catdog 7919 so it how big is your wiener
I like the quarter pound hot dogs to
Matthew Kobe 2016 12 know if we're
watching you plan the apes trailer
clearly you don't fall channel enough
just keep talking about screw her man
and yeah I put up my reaction a few
hours ago campy hey B says his homies
the new spider-man yelling reason he's
excited for it Tom Hollands on Hollins
our best friend PP dude that's great
that's the raid took Moulton 26 foxy
summer hell yeah hey you now has sent me
a notification saying
find your fans to hit the share button
hey share this hey fans could you share
this for the world please we would be
very interested 26 foxy summer sexy name
I'm glad you're a fan hey thank you
coming dude 10 Killa fousey I know the
new Thor trailers is gonna be cool I
hope no other guy playing Tom Holland
the guy plays spider man's best friend
it is a friend official high school cool
that's cool hey can't be AV you're an
actor dude we're looking for actors just
to see where they're out of their career
and if they're important enough to talk
to you cannot discuss you know but do
you 10 kill of food busy 42 fans of this
broadcast knows a lot of pressure and
we're not used to Tom so many people 73
a lessee see half her face in the
thumbnail that's a cute hat half I say
about that all right yeah yeah thank you
found five ground Guiteau for sharing
that hey so according to you now tips
you're not supposed to read all the tips
that they keep telling you but were
that's not our style we will we will
inform everyone of what you now is
saying to do better on you now they're
saying that we should you know try to
get once there's like a hundred i don't
know i don't know something about bars
and donations and someone explain to me
how you now works then we'll kick off is
this movie news talk to someone tell me
how you now works how does it work what
does it mean what are these bars people
keep talking about a curse on says he
makes money on this thing tyrone magna
says he makes money and Jenna are not
the kind to actually go let's see how
this works we just go let's go alive and
have it explained to us okay to Matthew
Kobe he likes Tom be became a fan thank
you Tom be was the be sad for big
balling
three lage Louise oh wow hey we got we
got bean bars I don't know that means
those are money's some honey I feel for
talking about nothing I guess wait
people pay people every live stream to
talk about them every time someone sends
us money i will take a drink out of this
corona but i won't drink it all if they
do if someone donates like 50 bucks i
will smoke a bunch of weed right to pay
for the weed i'm smoking Tony Gil tony
gilroy Tony Gil come in here I see my
neighbor through the window John F
you're a fan yo say hi to the world
right now we're on this thing called you
now John F F we got we got 25 viewers in
on this [ __ ] hood and we're doing a live
stream right now anyway how are you two
oh good where you off to I just gonna
get the mail all right good get yo mile
you know do normal [ __ ] all right well
you're welcome to hop on your phone and
watch us on you now and you're uh oh
this is it said of being answer your
questions and ones yeah asking you you
could donate bars like Richie G and Tom
Burns look at the bars that are donating
what do bars equivalent to I don't know
what their money what is the math of the
bars John this guy cash he's not chad is
a cash I believe guys tell me what the
bars are pleased you guys be in my movie
with what's your movie pitch us your
logline and if we like it we might steal
it what's your idea John F I'm glad
you've been a fan rich that means you
have to drink Oh as you have water sign
and I just assume that means drink do
you Tom Burns you burn like the stds my
ex ex girlfriend hat not my ex for my
understanding she didn't have a single
STD
this is kind of live streaming
techniques i have how to engage viewers
yo 10 kilo [ __ ] oh okay you know what
let's kick off let's kick off the movie
news talk Tony do you see the 16 second
trailer for Fast & Furious 8 the fate of
the Furious I don't know about that
title that's a great title because faint
rhymes with eight ah now I saw like the
behind the scenes of them making that
technical teams are for you whoo BTS
spent a hundred million dollars to make
that eight second teaser do you know
that really I don't know Oh Benjamin's
um guys guys I don't know what the bars
mean why isn't there like an outline to
explain to me what bars mean okay look
let's talk about the fast and the
furious a real fast okay let's call it
really is the faith of the furious the
fate of the Furious 8 i'm excited for it
I feel like we're probably gonna
capitalize a little bit more off her
vessel uh-huh you know like I kind of
sucks up taking jordana brewster out of
it I know Paul Walker passed away and
her character was married and had a kid
and the last movie all her role really
was was being a mom um but still jordana
brewster hot [ __ ] and she should have
totally been in this next fashion [ __ ]
solid Benin's next fast and furious move
in I mean Ashwin remin aaron has a good
point how many last rites has this
series had like six at this point it's
never gonna stop having last rides this
is our that's right this is art an
asteroid that's what we got series in
the next film o our next ride I think I
debris last choice for that franchise
would be as like at the 10th movie they
finally start to realize that they're
caught in some kind of time loop where
they do a crime and get out hmm but then
they never got out mmm and so like they
keep waking up like 10 runs earlier so
they can get into a new crime and it's
like grandpa okay I think I think this
one's gonna be cool this is a director
of The Italian Job and straight out of
Compton it's got notice how to make
exciting movies okay problem I feel like
now his last movie was about a lot of
black people and I don't feel like we're
really getting it again much
like Tyrese Gibson or Ludacris that's
like that's what half gary Gray excels
that is capitalizing on the black actors
in the movie do you really dude John
this is a live string you can't say
anything wrong when you're a lot of it
he just staying exactly a very great
actors all right very gray likes the
black actors I mean what is lips wayne
Johnny guys don't you guys know what
Dwayne Johnson is super Samoan he's not
some mo is John yeah the rock or those
used to call Samoans must this is what
it's like hanging out with John has
never just invested in the moment of
what's going on I'm sorry that is on his
laptop Stuart bloom house were know when
I try to juggle my [ __ ] combi gave us 50
likes that's a lot of likes yeah I've
only had about 10 people say they like
me in my lifetime not including YouTube
I thought you know you're just worth one
light this guy's worth 50 likes so his
dad is black and his mother's blacks so
he is black anyway okay so ya been jeff
gary Gray has his black actor to have in
fat the new Fast and Furious movie yeah
10 kilo fuzzy okay yeah a lot of a lot
of fans know that he's black see the new
Fast and Furious is gonna be great with
f gary Gray you know like in that little
eight second teaser we saw like him
driving a car doing Johnson yeah
normally it's just like Dom need you to
do a job for me he doesn't see ya very
clearly you Dom hey what yeah um when
it's a new Schmo down okay okay John
you're not like invested it all in this
life dream with me I am no you're not
you're liking this thing you're not I'm
not like Gaza bands you can you guys
tell John how much of a do she's being
this what happens so you look he's not
even tension just not paying attention
you take your insulin fine fine book all
right on a serious note I think the fate
of the Furies is going to be
I think it's gonna be a really good time
charlize theron as a villain we all saw
what she does in the snow white and the
huntsman films she is she's a great
villain she's a fantastic villain fun
she was the villainous job guess who the
village she was the one who killed off
all of marlboro killed said every and
then ever norden had to go in there and
then try to seduce her yeah yeah that
was what that movie Wahlberg shows about
the restaurant and punches charlize
theron in the face but it turns out
she's really Michael Caine the whole
time in the original new happy John
joins a live stream late week jokes I
got so many jobs man I gotta keep them
all online hickam said everyone is
trying to cut weight we're on YouTube
right now to where bring him to me we're
on YouTube where are we on youtube
doesn't show we're on YouTube it doesn't
show us on our page go to like the
homepage I am on the off by you mean
like the channel stages know just like
the you to know why we just type in the
real rejects oh we are live oh my
goodness that is crazy Wow guys we're
learning how this works this is a brand
new thing do you Jack McGinnis 960 guys
you guys start asking some questions you
got to tell us how these bars work
because I need to know that it tend to
everyone here properly [ __ ] got bars
son at door start a business oh damn
there's a lawyer Danny gun he wants a
shout out hello to their awesome from
van nuys did Samuel random I'm drinking
a corona extra I like it a little extra
because I like to overindulge you know
what I mean I like when people just
comment their name horse piss dude is it
pissing and John call granny's peach tea
it was granny's peach tea miss killer
101 we do live in Los Angles and ball
what is your news a thousand bars what
is that like two million dollars I've no
idea what is a thousand barczyk way to
you tomm be you just keep dough
and I don't know what to do for you and
return i'ma text tool is I feel I feel
bad Richie goliyan donated 15 bars dude
you my homeboy you my um you know
there's got to be like a Filipino word
for the n-word you know you know like
black people have the n-word there's got
to be like a Filipino word for that I
don't know about that John you speak to
garlic yes I do what would you say that
dessert that you guys love can't be a be
um I want you to know we are gonna beat
Christian and market a snow down one day
we're gonna own their [ __ ] asses I mean
we're the Christian and mark of the real
reason I yeah we so a thousand bars is
ten bucks whoa that's a much smaller
percentage than two million dollars i
thought yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna text
Alyssa Ferrari due to mavin place to
Matthew Kobe 2016 so Greg should be the
new Nightwing I'm telling you guys I
just reread Nightwing year one I love
that I'm starting to reread night
waiting the hunk for the Oracle I'm most
of the country the Oracle but that would
have been a very appropriate thing
anyway I have what a concept that wasn't
mine and now one is gonna steal it I
have a concept that would combine that
Nightwing year hun for the Oracle is
kind of be like my Batman instead of a
Nightwing and I'm gonna run hey just
start on the Warner Brothers lot goes oh
this must be important tonight would
bite that youtuber guy whoever picks it
up is gonna know the real rejects Greg a
lie i know that i know every security
guard at Warner Brothers watch is the
real Russian live stream once I'm like a
friday afternoon get word out it's
chigga who should play Dracula oh man
Luke Evans Greg what's your favorite
horror film Tom be since you've been
donating like three million dollars to
us this whole time I'll tell you my
favorite horror film would have to be a
probably scream I think screams the best
horror movie man it's everyone knows how
it's like not they're just so good
a lessee dirty
that girl who donated to us Jenny
confetti from gym from Jenny my God look
at the end right now we got a little
luck we got a little boxing Norton it
Jenny where's this live stream is me
just talking really loud over everyone
sorry I've given any content where you
got it all it's okay when we in 20
minutes will sir professor wrap Asia
okay look there's news that we want to
cover there's some movies you want to
cover guys it's about dick head pool for
a second Deadpool uh can we sue she
looks like a lessee care oh you can
barely see her she was uh I mean you
might be young huh got a better for that
[ __ ] you never know when you got young
uns oh oh my goodness oh dude the pro
lessee donated 15 bars as well you know
what role se is right no it's that that
is a type of circumcision done on a
non-believer by a professional yeah like
an orthodontist yeah aight for inter
college close closer same materially if
your stream comes trending more will
come look Deadpool they're getting a lot
of talk laters I'm gonna try to get on
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey horror I think for this
is a different more I mean you know a
lot of horse or slap with horse as a
good
I pause the proper term make sure that I
or absolutely compensated just
constantly wherever you're one of my
support England's Apple too it's so
weird to see all this time what's going
on like Tim eller just did it I saw
Henry Miller was like you don't know
this [ __ ] that people are assume lying
about me saying I wanted to make this
big all that crap is actually true and
yes for a horrid is Lindsay what's up
Canada I think that I want to know the
real story why he left from from what he
was saying Tim Miller that he was he
wanted to make us the one he just met
yeah he said he didn't want to beef it
up and be easier had a much more special
effects into [ __ ] it's so yeah now and
he didn't want to cast a he wasn't
hell-bent on casting chandler AZ cable
either yeah so now yeah I'm really
curious as to what that where that news
came from and what his idea really was
and Simon Kinberg said that they won't
get like the way how Deadpool was very
original very fresh they said they
wanted to go even more original and more
fresh and and to not you know do what
mode not just continue the first one or
not make it just bigger yeah he I liked
whatever I read an article about this is
quoting Ryan Reynolds's and I'm gonna
say like Deadpool is having all these
conflicts in the news they're all like
everyone's talking
really voice I liked it they
one seems to have taken them the
approach in there and not make it just
gigantic because it was successful you
know and that's I I like the yeah that's
very true that's very true let's look at
youtube really drab fire shock says we'd
rather on a Batman suit of the Dead Pool
C Batman I'll take the Deadpool pseudo
member good move to beach [ __ ] you
know that you're both [ __ ] the [ __ ]
takes a Deadpool suit over a Batman suit
I feel like I maybe get the belt with
everything that the Batman has cuz yeah
you get the belt you know Jenny 6 not
only 3,000 bars Thomas noting at three
thousand or 15 runs I mean shiny jeez
mom has a bigger dick than Jenny but he
more mayonnaise it were sensitive I
don't think jenny has we shouldn't see
any people this way she wants you to
want to be beauty y we could use some
huge any profile picture I would say
they're gonna succeed at being a beauty
guru all you gotta do is look at the
marriage or all fosho that's what I read
I don't win friends and influence here
working out great hey we're trending no
we tryna how that happen in the mail and
atmosphere is part of the show you are
your Andy Richter we're gonna like cut
to you
do
cuz kind of pop over oh [ __ ] there's a
bull Tony right there oh dear I can't
just like sink into the county fair well
there you go oh yeah Jonathan pack a man
here that guy who's always on screen
junkie so he's the guy who got me help
get me on screen junkies jpg JPEG and
you um the other story I wanted to talk
about was the fact that they're doing
their they're postponing justice Lee to
or they're making room for them to film
the Batman standalone movie first and
they're already working on that they are
working on it but I think they wanted a
film it before the Justice League part 2
which just makes me wonder like how much
rewrites did the last finale the finale
of Justice League part one knee because
they wanted to shoot those back-to-back
yeah so I'm assuming it was supposed to
be part 1 and then it ends on a note
we're in order to finish the story of
Justice League part 1 you gotta watch
part 2 you lie right that's what I'm
assuming so now they're like we want
with the Batman movie in between that
though before we release just asleep are
too so i was wondering like what the
hell's going on I don't understand their
their slate at all like we're gonna make
justice league all right here we go what
do we do we make Batman and Superman
fight okay then what then wonder when we
get some movie okay then what then the
Justice League oh yeah okay then another
Justice League then what Batman no well
Aquaman now we're going to put like I
just wanted to get this put the [ __ ]
order I felt like I wanted to get the
Justice League out there the movie just
cuz they're like oh they didn't get
enough from just the files like that
that's what I didn't understand our
bowels want to see all of them already
very show that they exist that's what I
don't get about this because I thought
Batman was slated for 2018 and they said
in the article the Justice League 2 is
2019 so I'm like why are they moving it
at all it seems like they plan to put it
out because right now the only good
thing to DC EU has going for itself is
Ben Affleck as Batman and a cool Wonder
Woman trade heard about that that's not
going pretty well so they're trying to
like capitalize Batman right now
I'm really hoping live I find Johnny's
last night i'll be live by night night
at free or die hard by night will be
great I hope it's great because Ben
Affleck needs that film to be very well
received right now I mean he on board is
attached to write and direct the Batman
movie but he will have people worried if
Y by night is not received well yeah
yeah yeah you need a need something to
actually get into words like not just so
fast paced and they're doing so much
actual I feel like if the Batman could
be like really just about the band story
I really have to like get around with
Bobby seems really quickly jump in a
different story now oh I just thought
Phil that's gonna make a little better
just got slowed down a little bit i'm
pretty sure everybody would enjoy a
Wonder Woman Batman flesh and then they
just brought to justice league team
stuff up that really does there
believing bare ass just to get them all
out there yeah yeah well and I don't
know like like the simple linear uh
keeping track of where the store PBS and
suicide squad was like difficult enough
so so I'm a little I'm a little
concerned if they're moving stuff around
I guess but or if they're delaying
things like I don't know like DC really
needs this and Ben Affleck roads to not
[ __ ] quick we're gonna take a break in
the movie news pre-owned nerd said same
rent random controversial disgusting
things because a random person the chat
told you to okay I got one oh I'm sure
Donald Trump is the reincarnation of
jesus christ and he hasn't come here to
impregnate me yeah yeah I'm giving birth
to the baby of Christ that's actually
why I'm the reincarnation of Mary
Magdalene the only way Trump could get
to Greg is by becoming the president
because that's the caliber is the only
caliber people Greg will hold court wins
Donald Trump was a super villain what
would a supervillain name be Ultron age
of shrubs captain use huge a Jonathan
pack he asked who could replace me the
NIA monster Dracula
I know you really do love Luke Evans i
was still i was thinking um uh who's
that Pacific wearin [ __ ] Charlie
Hunnam yeah I think Charlie Hunnam would
be a regular who could really the new
Dracula they say one um well if I was
making the Hollywood decision i would i
would cast like tom hiddleston or
somebody that people know why God has
honor it'll 100 people just love and are
good actors now no dude look did you not
see the mummy trailer they're not doing
the universal monsters there's gonna be
a whole new kind of Dracula beginnings
as like super speed and super string
who's basically is Suzy out mutant in
exactly i'm thinking Michael B Jordan
for Dracula yeah let's do it blacker
acula sounds good blacula Dracula has
the universal monster right I would love
if if like blaxploitation came back jpg
I don't know why you're asking us this
question I'm answering it for you the
past minute and a half right now yeah
car crash outside our craft oh yeah
nasty car crash one of Tony go look
cutting your seat widened go see Tony
movement with my curtains open oh I see
lights Tony's knocking over more [ __ ]
Lou this was the first time I think I've
ever heard that happen where you hear
tire screeching and be followed by a
nasty car driving of glass just move it
is we have a sony you see anything is it
nasty I'll be right back in 15 seconds
all right you take first watch or I'll
take first watch all right guys II now
so anything that you want to just talk
to john about what if it was your car
that's sire we're on a different side of
the room so it's not occur thankfully
show you okay yeah if it's not gonna hey
I'm gonna bring they want to set up like
horror nights
we'll want to see this car crash can you
point the load count do it all right we
got bring the laptop this is real real
it's a breaking music that I see it if
you guys can see through the trees you
can barely see it our going outside
we're going outside Wi-Fi you guys got
seeing his car oh I get Wi-Fi I don't
know that's you not too bad oh do I have
the you know app on my phone I don't
know any of this stuff works plan you
have to use social media cool if only
you were like on social me anyway sorry
almost got that exclusive sorta goes
crazy dude we think Kong's going o be
good yeah wanted that topic uh kind of
I'm a little I'm a little concerned
about Kong Skull Island um it you know
like we didn't talk the greatest of that
trailer and we got a lot of backlash on
that well there's a really dislike EO
what I noticed about youtube if you
don't like a trailer you get a lot of
people hate you like too many trailers
people just tell you that you love
everything why do you love everything
well if you don't or if you have the
middle ground where you're like I hate
this every trailer then we'll give an
okay remission um okay let's look at
some people who donated real quick whoa
I don't know how many bars that is dang
I think dropping board thousand to ten
bucks dude Jenny you are [ __ ] awesome
dream everyone has to go check out Jenny
G right now she's a beauty guru well
thank you do wrong she is fandom was
your peanut DC take no Disney after cars
three
what is around where there's a good
question up here it's good Oh armie
hammer a Deadpool gaming 80 205 said
what do you guys think about the rivers
of armie hammer is real answered I think
armie hammer was fantastic in the Lone
Ranger and I think that he should
totally be the next Green Lantern well I
garmi hammer I don't I don't know if I
armie hammer his army hammered to me
right now so like I think he can act but
I don't know well no like I'm pretty
sure I'm not seeming where I'm like
where I think of the character name but
I think of just his name you know um and
so Green Lantern I think he's got the
acting ability to do it and I don't know
if I can see it being like the bad leg
if I'm excited other choice um ashwin
ramadhar and said did you hear about
PewDiePie deleting his channel at 15
million subs dead I think you should do
it you know didn't he delete like he
just takes footage from games and shows
it and just you know gives his emotions
based off of that and I just think
that's stealing content I thought he
already shut down and he shut down like
a different channel is like a troll I
don't know thank you i would love to be
cable and Greg would be a great Deadpool
I don't think I'd be a good Deadpool I
think you would i think i'd be a great
like low-key yeah i got like a low-key
presence exactly i feel like i'm people
actually there's one room you be a great
low key especially in this area you look
the most like evident I think I think
I'm more of the low key type that is not
Japanese are the Black Widow Black Widow
dead fish Sandra aces gonna delete it
then make a new one and start over why
would he [ __ ] do that why would you
do that just to show that you could do
it take all this size drivers I mean
when did they just recently on people to
resubscribe perhaps some people took my
coming a little serious but what about
beauty pie and then um shadow ninja 565
wants to know am I related jessica alba
that's yes yes and married I'm she's
Mary more famous than her i'm way more
famous than her how many subscribers is
Jessica Jessica Alba's YouTube page that
I will not now ya see one a designee I
got [ __ ] on me someone's gonna direct
meant a great stuff and [ __ ] about you
you matthäus wants me the same at Theus
you're a [ __ ] Ryan for Batman John for
Robin Tony for penguin ah bingo hell
yeah why should a sanguinary port of us
or just porn in general whoa this sand
lady donated bars to us Thank You Sandra
okay she's 22 years old some meaning i
can give you a genuine compliment hey
Sandra you're [ __ ] hot Satan's a real
cop how to win friends and influence
people just laying out on the table yeah
honesty I don't friends influence
people's the greatest pickup artist book
iron man would probably win given the
versions we've seen so far you would
away in Iron Man or Batman keep in mind
there's no prep time because real is he
he would it I think Iron Man with one
with no prep time yep sadly you mean
like Tony Stark yeah like not without a
suit oh no it's a demo it destroy to
start I'm say Bruce Wayne and Tony Stark
Bruce why would Bruce Wayne would [ __ ]
about yeah it'd be kind of difficult to
beat iron man because he's called iron
man yeah bunch of comments are missing
out on youtube if if can like rock it
around town on your jet boots while like
Batman has to either take a plane or
like swing he's probably good who could
I ever been is probably gonna take that
but yo we got we got four dislike
YouTube video on an ex what the [ __ ] Don
Rex shut up to you on show oh hai ba Oh
honcho lakes high five weeks han cholo
like the Han Solo that does like like
geek jewelry they had I was a design
designer con just recently and there was
a whole han cholo booth they had really
cool [ __ ] go check aman ya a big issue
Kumar said hey man the next Bond actor
easily Tom Hiddleston yeah or mark
Strong or mark wahlberg or marc webb
[ __ ] it let's just get the rock in there
yeah the righteous weight is a bond
James Bond oh the police are here for
the car [ __ ] how do you donate bars to
us go on you know if you want you now
and you donate bars to us there and I
assume you have to like your credit
cards from my understanding the bars um
I don't know how they work Greg I don't
really know how to feel like I deserve
don't get some bars from you guys we're
not really doing anything but weren't
that hold on greg did you like me yeah i
did like BB ray liotta yeah whoo really
know that was hands is that be moody do
wise matthäus ain't so bad you're a [ __ ]
okay doesn't say it like you like in a
sketch though like like Dennis Hopper
and blue velvet hmm we should probably
close that window with the kids standing
on the ledge yeah now there's a car
crash Brendan no but we love you we love
you love you brandon novo hello to
dallas texas clink in those bottles
Matthew Oliveira I love Brazil to Bob
job gets the most beautiful men there
with the greatest asses they run Greg
run what's on mls g the charger all
right let's get another news story ends
let's get it on a new story in here
thanks tones food associate producer
Tony Gil right here yeah make sure that
should inking sure powerful you know
Zachary ginger is is on you know hell
yeah well done all rights talk about
another news story yes another one we
have let me look it up on facebook
Messenger you know what uh oh I don't
remember I did remember for a second I
drank this beer all right Greg ala
Cloverfield oh yeah there's gonna be a
new club revealed movie next year yes
you know people they think Fox might be
trolling because
that god particle film they said they're
not gonna do that anymore you know JJ
Abrams is known to be [ __ ] liar in
this business I think they're messing
around right now Jay Abrams full of [ __ ]
yeah James how's it gonna come over name
one KJ Abraham's has given us what move
it we were catching up on West role than
we know JJ's one of the producers and we
were I just kept thinking like I think
JJ's whole concept with anything he
makes is he wants people to go ask
themselves what the [ __ ] is going on
right yeah it's a good way to be how he
does all of his movies or shows it's all
going I don't know what's going on but I
got sick around and find out John you're
moving to the common Sufi I'm sorry I
like when people just right one person
just like Tyra Banks really wanna see me
but you ready for fast date we're always
ready fast day Greg oh I don't know what
do you guys think if DC have Marvel and
DC Comics and better in the 90s or now I
would actually like to know that because
the thing is I wish start reading a lot
of comic books and I just don't have the
time like I'm so interested in and how
the actual written and drawn out stories
have progressed and whether or not like
right now is a good time because they've
like relaunched a lot of their comics
and and and it's a new time in that in
that room that I just don't know much
about you raider football 5427 said
anybody here the 40 minutes of loading
the show to people today first off what
[ __ ] are they showing four minutes of
lotion and to whom are they showing you
sure like 15-20 minutes tops and then I
could get on board with that like it's
some special presentation well it's 40
minutes though that's more than a third
of the movie yeah actually somebody
described it as act one like we saw acts
all along Act one yeah nurse to be I
don't care it's what brings last outing
well and they're making and and from
what those comments have said that was
one of the stories we looked up today
actually I want the comments a lot of
them said is this feels like a legit
modern-day Western neo Western like hey
westerns take their time usually in
there there longer films so hey for 40
min attacked one's a little long I'm
happy to hear the response with John
we're trying to do a movie talk here
it's gonna be three hours so I hope it
is six hours you guys will take breaks
people people want to see no like you
got to give your criticisms right we got
to be like John campeon Collider we
gotta be like the schmoes all right
here's my criticism for for this or my
concern 40 minutes if you remember the
Wolverine the first two-thirds of that
movie are really damn good def finales
where it kind of goes wrong so even in
the first 40 minutes are and this from
the same director though same director
if limes make like a fly think oh just
walk back into that would happen did you
just watch Barry 420 um hey wait a
minute scar we screen junkies wannabes I
want to address this the [ __ ] is that
man I don't know board hey to board as
[ __ ] what do you mean by that I love
screen junkies i watch me I want to go
back on movie fights i feel like when i
went on movie fights I think fully
understand the whole concept in terms of
I just came to argue my point I didn't
really think about taking down the other
people's points I feel like now I'd be
great at doing that too if you guys can
go till screen junkies you want me back
on movie fights I will do it I will own
someone here earlier oh damn do we got
likes from Lindsay Lindsay a talk with
Lindsay before she's a hot lady in
Canada he's super she might be married
already last I heard she was engaged
which is good my definitely uh well it
depends on what it is yo mama's ali
haider likes wow wow that's cool okay
here earlier i can't find the comment
now said um you know i'm gonna type it
in on the search okay this Lord said
Krista I mean in the flick pic which is
the real rejects on the Schmo down oh
[ __ ] that would be crazy that would be
great don't think it's gonna happen
because in all honesty
just had a baby it's John ha she said it
ooh oh she would oh she's she told me
she was into you really she said she was
I was I was incredibly jealous oh thank
you what do we name it [ __ ] I have such
a bad fault she's gonna break you guys
apart we will name it dan Danvers look
yeah so um [ __ ] yeah the reason I
don't think they would put stockman and
flick pick up against us is because um
we just don't have the movie knowledge
reputation even though I think we can
totally match them and I feel like we
take good time to give very in-depth
reviews I think for a lot of people who
do trail reactions I feel like we tend
to do our videos a little bit longer
because we can to have a little bit
deeper but still people just think we
only do reactions then we call it dick
hey we're slowly changing the tide of
perception slowly slowly people are
noticing we actually know movies yeah
hey thank you for voting real rejects
for YouTube rewind 2017 would be awesome
dillard man dude gamer wants to know do
you like the new Ghost Rider yeah yeah
like yeah I haven't mexi I like the idea
of the new Ghost own i'd have to see
some of the show I have gained watching
the show I gotta hang out with my
homegirls good Camille again I enjoy
what they're doing cuz you mean agent
shield goes up and down could be the
show or not but to bring in the ghost
writer I felt like it just brought that
show right back upwards it's actually
really good and uh I like how they
anything you touch it he turns into like
a flaming car or something like go dope
like they chose the Charlie charger over
a motorcycle but kind of just like come
on get the motorcycle ready you need to
have more cycle see what they showed how
I got the chain in the show which was
dope I enjoyed that says like Deadpool
made I've not that ghost rider is
actually getting me interested in at
least checking out an episode of agent
shield again so like in that way I I've
kind of never really been interested in
that show and I've seen a few episodes
like they're they're okay like they're
not my bag
exactly like they're not things I get
really excited tea bag yeah they're not
my team bag from prison break I felt
like masturbating oh yeah but I but
ghost rider seeing that footage when we
did the trailer reaction i actually got
excited to see it i like the idea anyway
cousin like the movie get the movies
then they got the netflix specials so
when it comes to Marvel e yeah pretty
good but the show falls off sometime
it's almost like the like arrow and
flash are like sometimes they have just
filler episodes because because I got 24
goddamn episodes yeah you got to feel a
lot and it's like you can't be as like
in-depth as like the netflix or
something so just like one here's a
couple filler episodes but they do a lot
of interesting [ __ ] in that show see
more of these like a premium cable and
Netflix shows them I'm sort of like yeah
I don't think shows were necessarily
meant to go on for 24 hours easy Hey
look the follow the 11th left the common
here said hey Greg my name is actually
ryan from the UK london i love your
guys's channel and jerrys wavy hair in
your masculine beard oh my Plus recently
broke up with my girl [ __ ] mask watching
you guys really helps oh thank you so
much do you thought I'd be 11 Ryan
listen I know what it's like to go
through a breakup and I don't know if
you guys ever heard about this but I
went through a breakup a la carte breaks
heart heartbreak stuck and I don't know
if you guys heard this I'm a hot time I
was broken up with two I put my name out
there as really Greg you guys might have
not heard about this but that's what
happened there's not many people found
out about it hug it out give you just
give you like an Internet hug right now
okay right that listen you want the best
advice go on craigslist craigslist
there's a sexual called casual
encounters andhra casual encounters you
can put down your pictures a picture of
your thing a ling and ding-a-ling-a-ling
or wherever you Brits call it it's
always a good idea to lead with the
picture of your penis people like that
yes especially when it's a surprise and
they didn't ask to see your penis if
they can see it that way I think people
react the best I noticed the best post
on craigslist
casual encounters is when the guy shows
his dick and he's like looking for a hot
latina forties big tits and I hope
she'll like my dick enough this perfect
sexy woman to come over and blow me and
I think I think that's your best shot
man at getting over like in those posts
though they have to throw a little like
tweak of what is weird about them like
oh and also I only Justin cups like it's
just a little something this is why I'm
weird you know yeah it can't just be
like showing digging an ass for the girl
exact what a little weird to what 2017
movie do you want to see most right now
I'm aiming for Logan that's what I'm
aiming for ya at least of the comic book
movies definitely Logan I just I just
want it to be get out time hi even say
logging off of like love and spider-man
mooing that's coming out clack dimming
looks rug one buys my name is Alex said
on the knee Wolverine cool dude it you
got that pic where you fork c4 yeah
bring it out break and then you just got
to borrow my chops tape or ace ventura
what's your here this is my new uh is
mine your hair stop with my [ __ ] cat
hair dried up hairspray falling on the
ground um yeah hey what guys this is the
best that like I promise you than this
live stream will go a lot smoother and
you don't be a bunch of no it's that hey
we witnessed an accident we got I talked
about some stuff we saw a car wreck
together so we we went through some [ __ ]
that was lived yeah except I'm not gonna
go to my mail and won't be here second
time getting much more guys look dude
you wanna be bar hand Steve a lot of
people you're definitely Bucky yeah
that's what he said yeah you're Bucky
Jonas Cyclops okay I'll tattoo and your
beast okay damn I'm getting some great
white all got penguin why haven't the
Avengers acknowledged that cat
in America is totally a virgin because
we don't do say he's like at her 80 year
old virgin he's like a committed priest
yeah my vocation is saving city from
total direction I don't have time I just
can't get it past like men cap probably
want to be so down all the time he got
laid a little bit it maybe you didn't
have sex with Peggy dim bone black widow
he didn't have sex with Peggy's neff
nice or whatever she was and civil war
you know he's a virgin and talked about
this I'm sure on one damn movie I'm sure
that Tony Stark is has at least ribbed
him he's gotta be some quips in the
hallway you know on those days just
gotta save the world can't bowl cut even
though my hair's exact like Tom Holland
bus hey where your hair however you want
where they that shizzle jody d0 343 said
john too cool for cyclops wow thank you
well he's as cool in the cartoons oh I
thought Cyclops cool I think she's like
a cool can who would I be if not Cyclops
then DD job would be a great game yeah I
think what I really good a scan on earth
hey Pradeep that's not as well learn the
convey Cajun x yeah Jake McGinnis is
back okay alright just a couple more
comments and I gotta go meet up with a
friend yeah we said we'd finish this
before five-thirty all real awesome
heroes with two E's yo someone asked you
Michael loco said do you want to see
marvel zombies in the Cinematic Universe
yes i love how great would that be
zombies in the MCU actually a friend of
mine made a Marvel Zombies short that
you can find on youtube my friend Scotty
made one which is pretty cool I would
love I would so be overjoyed if they
actually made a real marble zombies
movie I like rates like that's what i
want is is some of those other like
weird story lines like there's a comic
book there's a series of Congress where
Captain America becomes a werewolf I
want to see that look do though I think
like if old age of Ultron and set a
bunch of robots and there's just
bunch of zombies like the world war z
kind the ones i could run ya know when
you bring in that story like how do you
cuz i ain't all trying to end it like
how would you would you continue with
zombies in this world because i think
all the zombies end up killing everybody
and like start trend of the planets in
the comics look I think when the MSC you
makes their final movie it should be
Punisher kills the marvel universe very
cool they just finally get Jon Bernthal
like like you leave Jon Bernthal
completely out of the movies until the
MCU reaches about the year 3100 where
the like guys I think we're out of
stories that's then again ringing Jon
Bernthal he's still alive BAM Punisher
kills the MCU hello from Costa Rica you
think of times worst movies of 2016
x-men two brothers grimm daredevil
spider man who went spider-man cool but
daredevil can regenerate what is
canceled either man the spider-man have
a healing factor he does yeah the last
same way yeah daredevil dude you're able
to have this regeneration factor what
are you talking about durable gets
injured knee stays injured for like days
and when I grew a hand back like I don't
think Peter Berger can grow a hand back
not a year not that you're Devils the
MCU right oh dear my Deadpool to it I
plays the Deadpool I'm sorry no you use
for some you said daredevil out why
advice does right mad definitely beat
the [ __ ] i heard Deadpool I thought of
Deadpool always always Deadpool I going
on daredevil poker spider-man when I
probably still my prediction for rotten
tomatoes score for Road one will be
eighty eight percent yeah eighty-eight
percent 92 I'm telling you honestly it's
probably a lot easier to predict what
the score will be after you watch the
movie but just based off the trailer so
that I haven't seen the movie I think
I'm gonna go over like an eighty-eight
percent I can keep I keep up with
goggles to it there's somebody called
Deadpool
in the thing and then you said daredevil
and then I thought of a bunch of red
character man daredevil and Deadpool at
spider-man are all [ __ ] red like damn
Jenny Gina tipa yells as ours Jenny
Jenny I don't know you but we got to get
to know you a little better why aren't
you posted any comments down here Jenny
it works we did have at least one news
item that was about alien covenant
apparently they screened a bunch of
footage from that too oh yeah they
scream like 20 minutes of alien covenant
which is also hard R and I'm excited for
that although not really i'm kind of
like disappointed and all this stuff
like I thought it would have been cool
to have your Prometheus equal and then
have your darren aronofsky neill
blomkamp Neill Blomkamp's aliens equal
that would have been yeah perfect shared
you number lately and because so many
times Ridley Scott and John I have
talked about this before like so many
times really Scott was like we're not
gonna lay daily we're not gonna liga
daily just like I'm making 50 you're
gonna David oh yeah alien and then
suddenly like after interview after
interview it just keeps you coming more
alien esque and I just feel like this
guy then again that's up for mythos was
Prometheus start off as an alien prequel
then he kept changing it so much should
work became nothing about alien when I
can't tell who to who to thank for that
you know because like I liked the idea
he was talking about originally and they
got away from that and I felt watching
the movie like the alien stuff was kind
of crammed in and so I don't know if the
I can't tell if this is the studio keeps
raining him in because everyone wants to
see that xenomorph yeah or if he just
really has a.d.d yo my name is alex's
batfleck vs christian bale batman easily
baffling that's lookin'-glass the fight
scenes i would say that just because has
already had waited he's always older
Christian Bale retires or even reaches
but well it's a dead like would just
just like get a machine gun like yeah
Levi Levi co-axial yeah that's like he's
got like the [ __ ] like gattling gun
on the front of the blammo really dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] Lindsay yeah she really does
want you oh cool like you
you share that with me several times I
think it's great when I can have an elk
your green tea I'm being dead serious I
think Lindsay's got on how much you want
Lindsay's terrific Lindsay come on sir I
kind Jenny where are your comments is
there a way where you do like a special
chat with people like just a one-on-one
chat are we gonna see office Christmas
party I feel like we should we I I often
i don't know if you know this but i look
back fondly on the day we saw the night
before for some reason like I felt kind
of Christmasy with you so uh yeah I
don't maybe I don't know if that movie
looks good or not but jonathan l if you
watched our video of who could be the
next joker you know I said Mark Hamill
would be the next live-action gym and
then a lot of backlash came in because
apparently a lot of people like Jay
little spectacular performance of the
Joker hmm yeah tomorrow I like things
about it tomorrow we are posting our
review it's already edited we are
posting our review of the Suicide Squad
honest ended cut carnage like spider-man
villain carnage like one of the seven
symbiotics this is only may destroy this
is only made more sense because my job
is within earshot but yes this is true
Oh see she has a husband named John or a
boyfriend or something he doesn't matter
at this point she wants you she's
willing to cheat on him do it do it no
no no high fly to john de sleep with
horror [ __ ] give me details no and know
how to share it on the next you now live
do you exactly dandy I don't like jared
leto as the Joker you know I have more
opinions in my review tomorrow but
rewatching film and even watching d the
extra footage I was like nah I don't I
just I I don't I'm kind of glad we
didn't get more Joker I don't like its
joke you know we win bad when weari
watched it I i had the same experience
but in a different way it's like the
first time I saw it I was like oh yeah
these scenes clearly look like they're
meant to be longer so there are moments
early
in their moments that I just don't know
in the second time around there's still
moments I think are really good but the
moments I didn't know before just kind
of felt annoying to me and yeah I'm now
looking back like all that stuff felt
like I he was sending we talked about
this like he was sitting people dead
pigs and condoms and stuff was like I I
I don't know I think you've just got
into playing the Joker and didn't
actually I couldn't tell like seeing the
extended cut I was a little bit like
maybe he just really gave him I think
he's strange bad for more would've been
a joker at like a Batman maze like if
there was a maze for a Batman throw
calorie that would be a great maze oh
yeah be a great maze a row gallery maze
they did a Suicide Squad attraction at
six is not the same [ __ ] thing do you
Jenny Jenny you got to talk to us you
were donating so many bars Jenny Jenny
it was a my hair mine isn't putting my
hair like this is making you want to
donate Jenny let's see Ali's don't need
the second most 20 ally le and jenni are
in competition they all want John they
both want you guys it's nothing about me
knowing about me it's always know the
girls don't ever donate for me they only
donate for you extended cut is still
drummer that time we went to destroy
your life and they brought us on stage
and you both started stripping yeah I
didn't get a single tip you made like
$2,000 and tips from men hey I have in
my lifetime this is a true story I've
been tipped as a stripper once before by
a very enthusiastic man with his
girlfriend dude Jenny versus Ali's the
next civil war man yes I'm excited that
donate the boats bar that airport scene
I know why generali haven't taught once
in the comment sections but they keep
donating and they're the only two girls
next door or I can see on this on this
live stream some reshoots made the Joker
look non-abusive I i wish the Joker
looked like any kind of character in
that movie because like every time he
shows up I'm like okay somes gonna
happen and he just like is crazy and
then leaves again and is inconsequential
tomorrow
yeah I think it sucks about a man like
it is felt like he just trying to be
like a crazy Joker just because the last
Joker was so good it's like oh I gotta
yeah this joker and be my own Joker
though I just gotta be weird now all
over the years when I saw with them
pre-owned nerd said what movie have you
learned from the most easily fahrenheit
911 it's the funniest movie you'll ever
watch right next to what was that what
was that movie the roger ebert set was
great about the Manson murders helter
skelter yeah hysterical hysterical phone
Schindler's List tears of laughter
throughout totally you mean he want to
know we learn the most from and these is
this is where I get my most comedy from
is is these great dark comedic pieces
like who would have thought Holocaust
black-and-white three hours could be on
a won the Academy Award and the Golden
Gopher funniest movies I feel like we've
learned exit desserts I feel like we've
learned a whole lot from evil dead I
believe maybe I learned how to cut off
my arm just ever so easily while hiking
ashlynn says his life is the worst I've
ever heard sorry about Jared Leto roomie
see that's the thing is like a hit that
joke like he is great so forced I can't
stand it for me
so it's a lot yeah there's a
you
it's really really bad it does feel
fresh the thing is the only the only
saving grace the second time around with
that character for me is I have no idea
what this guy is thinking and he's being
crazy I can't tell if that's authentic
or not and so in a weird wet and I don't
like him and he's annoying but that kind
of worked out cuz I'm not supposed to
like him like clearly he's not a
likeable character in the movie and
you're not supposed to understand I'm so
like in a way he held me at arm's
distance still so yeah someone asked
can't be AV what's the best score the
best score for that dark night I i dunt
dunt done did you don't don't or or her
veins was a snitch is that like really
percussive thing oh yeah like a chant oh
the bay ones cool oh yeah it's something
that is that do dilek do the gamers
posting a lot of weird [ __ ] right now
yeah Jenny why haven't you talked Allie
why haven't you talked you're just
giving us money you're treating us like
we're [ __ ] Dylan has crippled erect
more no less hell money I likes writing
some serious give us money but they
don't wash stripping I like a connection
spider-man trailer it's on YouTube our
reaction go check it look Jenny and
Allie are doing so much and Tony makes a
good point well you guys are going mr.
Jenny and Ally this is live look I could
do that thing Tyrone des'ree bounces his
boobs okay movie down this now donate
Jenny and Ally donate Jenny another
don't so nice that one does anyway don't
take back your donations we're gonna end
this video now no never we have to I
gotta go to this meeting at six if it's
in 10 minutes and it's like a 15 minute
drive thank you guys for tuning
and thank you to all you guys who
donated one real Nick thank you you got
a big trick Sandra a sams you got a big
a Tom Burns you earn my love Ali see Ali
makes me wanna pee pee Jenny g90 i was
born in the 90 to take america i care
guys take care of america hmm horny
someone said why people are totally horn
bubele suit watts you're welcome alright
for any in the stream good night we love
you I everyone we love you I decided I'd
love Jenni Ali thank you so much Lindsay
take care say hello to your bone your
baby Christine but yeah whichever